[Musik]
ein video nach dem andern habe ich es
versucht und den niederlanden
nach der online
unter
nun denn nun denn kelly denkt wohl
sie könnte mich herausfordern mich
eigentlich muss schon sagen das wollen
wir beeindruckende torte die du da
gezaubert hast aber dass du die schlacht
gewonnen hast bedeutet nicht dass der
krieg schon vorbei ist
ich bin ehrlich mit euch ich hätte
niemals gedacht dass kelly nach meinem
video sich noch mal trauen den ring zu
steigen aber dafür hat sie meinen
respekt geworden sie hat einen kuchen
eine torte fabriziert die wirklich
beeindruckend war nicht beeindruckend
für sallys torten welt verhältnisse aber
beeindruckend kellys verhältnisse das
heißt es nur für mich ich könnte jetzt
meinen hut ziehen und sagen kelly gut
gemacht und die sache wäre damit
gegessen aber so bin ich nicht so wo ich
nicht erzogen ich werde heute kellys
rache an ich rette kellys erdbeer
vanille torte oder so retten kellys tut
mir leid aber du kennst mich kelly kam
mit einem wiener boden um die ecke ein
wiener boden ich folgte einem strang im
konzept von einem tortenboden für drei
wiener böden brauche ich 9 300 gramm
zucker grün wie scheiße schon durch und
jetzt fangen erst mal so die richtigen
fand times an denn wir müssen das auf 45
grad erhitzen und dann erst wieder durch
früheren ich benutze einfach 60 grad
heißes wasser
wenn ich dann das 15 grad rein packe
gleicht das 15 grad des 60 grad aus 9 45
grad
[Musik]
also nehme ich jetzt doch kochendes
wasser und das wird in dem wasserbad es
so richtig
jetzt haben wir wirklich kochen ist
wasser
doch nicht ganz während es rührt holen
wir uns schon mal zitronenschale
also zitronenschale reihe das ist die
allerhöchste backkunst so ich habe die
schüssel jetzt richtig kalt ausgespült
damit sie auch richtig kalt wird und
pakets meine eier masse da rein und
jetzt weil sie beim rühren wieder auf 21
grad herunterkühlen
jetzt müssen unseren trockenen zutaten
mixen 110 gramm mehl 110 gramm stärke
will und stärke verrühren und wenn wir
dachten dass wirklich alles anstrengend
genug ist wir müssen 110 gramm butter im
topf erhitzen und dann wird auch noch
mal richtig kompliziert wenn das mit der
leckerste wohl aller zeiten wird hat so
meint eick hat jetzt 22 grad ich kann
nicht mehr warten
die schau war es wirklich ein absolut
perfektes ebenbild von mir durch ein
sieg werden wir das jetzt wie und unter
rühren mail ist jetzt untergerührt eine
kleine menge wieder machen zum butter in
den topf geben glattrühren eine kleine
menge das ist eine kleine menge dass
hier das geben wir jetzt so oben
restlichen und unterrühren
jetzt muss ich in den backofen backen
für zehn minuten bei 180° danach zehn
minuten auf 160 grad rund tagen noch
weiter packen die positive bild
[Musik]
das wird zunächst ich mache alles in ein
und überlaufen
es kommen aber egal
zehn minuten jetzt auf 180 grad und wir
sehen uns wieder
[Musik]
wenn ich die frucht einlage macht aber
jetzt gehe ich erstmal auftritt sport
machen weil ich da der boden ist
gebacken richterliches wartet noch so
viel arbeit auf uns unsere nächste
aufgabe ist eine frucht platte kelly hat
frische früchte reingemacht
[Musik]
aber da die nach einem tag schon so
schloss sich werden in einem kuchen ist
die frucht einlage die professionellere
alternative wir brauchen 500 gramm
erdbeeren oder milliliter wasser und
zehn gramm agha also ich habe noch extra
solche dinger gibt es rezepte und um das
game noch mal so richtig abzustimmen
habe ich torten ringe und torten retter
geholt ich meine das gute an bio
erdbeeren ist dass sie bio sind das
schlechte an die erbin ist dass sie
nicht behandelt sind und dadurch halt
superschnell gammeln 500 gramm
jetzt nehmen wir unsere 500 gramm
erdbeeren machen auch wenn man es mit
essen darf das grüne weg vielleicht
beweist das auch macht wirklich einen
tee daraus
[Musik]
bevor sie in den topf kommt schneide ich
sie noch mal kurz
und ab in den topf und jetzt kochen wir
sie fein pürieren und in einem topf
scheiße fein pürieren haben länger man
kann es mit wasser oder saft auffüllen
später ich nehme cranberrysaft weil er
auch so schön sauer ist und sauber macht
lustig wenn wir wieder im multitasking
warnen muss nutzt ich muss die torten
und lätta mit folie auslegen debug ringe
drauf machen dann agar agar mit wasser
aufkochen und dann das alles verrühren
während ich die frucht berühre das ist
jetzt sagt mit agar agar gemischt und
das soll jetzt zwei minuten kochen an
dem wir es zu dass fruchten müsse jetzt
sehr flüssig ausgabe so aussehen soll
das führen wir in unseren reihen ok
könnte das jetzt nach draußen stellen
damit das draußen abkühlt solange unsere
frucht platte hart wird kümmern sonst
parallel die deko und dafür suchen wir
jetzt schon mal wunderschöne erdbeeren
raus so die allerkleinsten denk ich mal
zur seite denn die werden auch diese
sahnehäubchen drauf kommen und hier die
müssen jetzt trocknen und wir werden sie
wie kelly in schokolade tunken und dafür
mache ich jetzt kurz schokolade flüssig
politik wir machen jetzt drei stationen
während ryan trunk stationen und zwar
habe ich rot gold konfetti streife und
perlen gefunden gleich die steuern nicht
einmal konnten einmal perlen flüssige
schokolade ist da für mich ein bisschen
als ob ich so ein schnitzel panieren
würde ein so geht jetzt in die
schokolade was gut abtropfen und dann
rolle ich es in den perlen
okay noch zwölfmal
die kleinen plan funktionieren besser ok
[Musik]
kommen wir zu unserer nächsten deko
marshmallow blumen habe es im internet
gesehen man nimmt ein marshmallow
schneidet den so in streifen aber man
schneidet nicht durch so dann hat man
diesen marshmallow formte ihn einmal
links und das ist haben die marshmallow
blumen wir so originell marshmallow die
kette ja vorgegeben hat tunc den einmal
in schokolade und schon ist es eine
orchidee neuss
[Applaus]
aber das kommt noch braucht sagt
kitschig
[Musik]
lebensmittel kleber das mit kritik leben
allem eine blume diesen scheiß
lebensmittel kleber kaputt gemacht eine
pause irgendwann später neue blumen
gemacht zeige mache ich nicht selbst
gemachten fancy pudding sondern aus der
backmischung corinne pulver vier
gehäufte esslöffel zucker verrühren zur
esslöffel milch sollte muss ich noch die
restliche milch aufkochen und dann mache
ich ganz kurz den pudding und wir sehen
uns wieder wenn ich die kugel
zusammenstellen so viel später dass es
dem alten erzähler zu blöd wurde und man
einen neuen anstellen musste matthews
beck aus irgendeinem grund hatte kelly
während des videos ein graben da mache
ich natürlich mit nun stellen wir die
torte zusammen es ist endlich soweit ich
hab kein bock mehr
also wenn dieser bohlig das beste ist
was ich jemals in meinem leben gegessen
habt weinig und drehen wir das einmal
und da einfach jetzt schneiden drei
schichten brauchen wir
ich glaube es ein sehr saftige bodenborn
räder kommen her um ein gott dieser
boden ist so fein die bunteste steht ist
aus irgendeinem grund super hart aber
also machen wir zuerst zu erstmal mir
pudding drauf vanillepudding ich bin so
gespannt ob diese frucht platte guckt
sie euch an oh mein gott
brauche ich bin geradezu betrifft hat
kommt nochmal creme drauf dann kommt
jetzt laden nummer zwei und pudding und
frucht klare nummer zwei der gäste haben
gute zeit um zu googeln die wir einen
cream cheese frosting machen ich werde
jetzt einfach frischkäse butter und
puderzucker ein bisschen vanille aroma
miteinander verwachsen und dann haben
wir ein greenpeace france den ich habe
glaube ich aus versehen ein level cache
gemacht ob apple vorbild nahost-reise
[Musik]
außenkamera match nein ich habe es kurz
oder gefriert wurde ist nicht nicht erst
einmal außen rum machen so und die queen
verteilen das soll jetzt wieso naked
cache auswählen kelly besuch im wiener
boden ausgesucht er ist voll stressig
werden alle wissen ist da war ja lange
vor beiden toren
so und ähnlich wie schön aus jetzt
brauchen noch einmal den ring und hier
habe ich selbst gebrannte mandeln mit
roter lebensmittelfarbe habe ich gerade
in der pfanne gerührt kommt jetzt in der
mitte so kaufte richtig aus wie so eine
leckere kuchen und daran war jetzt 12
doppel 1 weil mein gott nicht gibt oder
creme mein gott ich hoffe ihr seht es
diese majestic hat jetzt nehmen wir
unsere kleinen erdbeeren und packen sie
jeweils auf so einen sahne blog jetzt
quetschen wir wirklich das allerletzte
an samen spritzt was wir noch hier drin
haben machen ein block in der mitte und
dann kommen jetzt noch eine erdbeere da
drauf und unsere blumen damit der hand
auch gut aussieht auch mit noch so kann
die seite so und das ziehen wir jetzt so
hoch
[Applaus]
nein ich hab nach 12 uhr bietet das ist
so eine rosa schokolade diamanten herzen
die kommen auch zwischen die erdbeeren
das musst du vor dem kühlschrank nicht
dass es schmilzt
[Musik]
es ist 21 13 ns-zeit anschneiden der
torte ist immer der beste zeit also
letzten mein gott ich hoffe man sieht
auch mit der schlechten beleuchtung aus
versehen habe ich die schichten perfekt
hinbekommen frage wie schmeckt der
gerettete gucken und sich zu fragen wie
schmeckt die rendite kuchenform kelly
letzt schreibt mein gott oh mein gott
hin
das richtige los es ist abends
abendstimmung die frucht einlagen sind
absolut krank lecker rabbiner boden
beste was ich jemals in meinem leben
gemacht habe und das wichtigste wie
schmeckt die erdbeere war das muss katie
echt erst mal toppen um mein gott ich
glaube das ist die leckerste torte die
ich jemals gemacht habe
aktuell notiert er wieder gewandelt
und wenn er sagt verschiedener button
zeigt steigt gerne in die kommentare
bis zum nächsten mal ich esse jetzt die
ganze torte auf